il reste bien des questions en prévision
de la réouverture des garderies du
québec est la province a sept jours pour
y répondre
on a trois grandes questions qui nous
trop grands groupes de questions qui
demeurent le regroupement des cpe
demande d'abord des précisions sur le
matériel de protection
sera-t-il obligatoire ou seulement
recommandée et surtout on ne sait pas
qui vont arriver le matériel ni comment
alors quand même plusieurs questions à
l'est avec le matériel de protection
les centres de la petite enfance veulent
aussi plus de détails sur la définition
des personnes à risque quels employés
ils sont considérés à parvenir au
travail et selon quels critères
s'interroge-t-il
nous on a besoin de savoir combien
d'employés vont pouvoir rentrer au
travail afin de composer nos horaires et
nos équipes de travail c'est dans une
semaine ça va arriver très très vite
et finalement les cp 1 se demande
quelles règles devront être respectées
pour répondre aux critères de la santé
publique et de la cmu insisté le
regroupement concède qu'il a déjà une
longueur d'avancé en raison de
l'ouverture des garderies d'urgence mais
des questions persistent
on ne part pas à zéro mais en même temps
si on occupe sur de nouvelles
indications tous ont donné parmi celles
là qu'est ce qui va être obligatoire qu
est-ce qui va être recommandé ce côté
des garderies non subventionnées la
grande question et financière combien
d'argent recevront tel pour les places
non occupées
en attendant la reprise complète des
activités parce que les milieux de garde
ne pourront accueillir tous les enfants
s'ils veulent respecter les règles de
distanciation physique nous la facture
qu'on a dû au méliès
elle est de 41 dollars par l'eau pour
les enfants qui sont absentes de la
garderie le ministre de la famille
assure que son ministère dédommagera les
services de garde
reconnue par la province qu'ils soient
subventionnées ou pas mais aucun chiffre
n'est avancé pour le moment les milieux
non reconnu eux craignent de ne pas
avoir compensation et de devoir se
tourner vers une aide individuelle comme
on n'a pas de permis
nous on doit s'adresser à la pcu si
jamais on veut une compensation selon
elle certaines de ces garderies ne
survivront pas le ministère de la
famille dit toutefois essayer de trouver
une solution pour inciter les garderies
non reconnue à ouvrir leurs
porte et accueillir les parents qui
travaillent dans les services essentiels
malgré toutes ces questions sans réponse
la plupart des milieux ouvriront le 11
mai mais ce sera tout un défi d'ici là
on va avoir une semaine 13 c'est la
passe ici il marie pierre merci radio
canada québec